[Music]
hello jsconf i'm tiger and i'm really
excited to be here and i'm honored to be
the last speaker before lunch i saw some
people already feel like it's lunch time
as is
to get things started let's do some
quick q a
raise your hand if you have a phone
me too i'm glad we all have something in
common
but raise your hand if you still have an
old phone that you didn't throw out
i'm not judging i mean
look at me
as you can see in the title i'm going to
talk about my pet project building
interactive wall decor
from junk phones this won't be a very
conventional tech talk beyond javascript
and iot we'll also be doing some arts
and crafts and then some woodworking
classes
really you're going to get free talks
for the price of one
a love about myself i'm a software
engineer at microsoft working on a new
web collaboration platform called loop
i'm a wpc participant and i previously
worked on a couple different browsers
like edge chrome firefox or android i
went to university in canada and i now
live in seattle i flew here all the way
from the pacific northwest
i was also born and raised in hawaii and
oh my god two claps in such short
succession
well you know how every family has a
designated computer person
that was me growing up
yeah i can see some knotting out there
too
while doing tech support i got to play
with something other than our old family
computer and when someone's phone broke
i got to keep it
i ended up with my grandma's motorola
phone a pixel that slipped out and then
hit the pavement
and one phone that i just straight up
found in the forest
and then i never threw them out
and then when i left for university and
flew across the ocean i brought this
pile of old cell phones with me
did i have a plan for that palo phones
no
am i a hoarder
yes but not if i come up with a project
for them
i also chatted with lots of other
developers and found that many of us are
hoarding old tech like phones and wires
that are probably gathering dust in your
closet right now
i want to show you how to repurpose
those of old phones and then give them a
second life we can walk out of here as
upcyclers not hoarders
so inspired by secondary smart devices
like smart watches and smart displays i
can start on taking my pile of phones
and turning into a second display where
information is spread across multiple
screens
it's called cell wall
this cell phone wall is a collection of
my old phones plugged into a raspberry
pi it can display text images other
visualizations all these different phone
screens are controlled by raspberry pi
and each one can show different info
well
let's go over to this table
my take away from lucky's talk yesterday
was that
everyone should be doing live demos
he was even kind enough to let me eat
one of his bananas so that's going to be
my lucky charm
and if anything fails we can blame the
hungarian bananas
all right perfect
okay
let's start with this
i'll be here to try and say hi
and immediately things aren't working
quite hard as i expected to but it's
okay i can restart the program and make
sure that things reconnect
[Applause]
there we go
things are showing up
and now i can say hello to jsconf with
this little board
so i also put this up on the oh can we
switch back to the slides
so i also put this up on the wall behind
me in my home office
and i think even turned off it's a much
cooler zoom background you know
someone's virtual background
and then
my fiance she's next to me at home so
she gets to have the same cool zoom
background
this is her being so thrilled that she
had to explain what it is yet another
time
someone works like this we're going to
break down this diagram and see how each
of these components work individually
and then put them back together
so let's start with this pile of phones
and the wall
we'll get started by building a shopping
list of hardware needed i live i live in
an apartment so i wanted to make this
removable from the wall i used to use a
foam board but then i upgraded to this
wood panel
i started off arranging all these phones
on the floor and then figuring out about
how much space is needed
once i had some rough measurements i
went over to the hardware store picked
up some light plywood and then got some
sandpaper to send on the edges
and the pen and the look you were going
for you probably want to paint it too
finally we need tools for mounting this
panel onto the wall and you can nail it
in or by command strips
next onto the phones
after gathering some old phones back
from my closet i start attaching them to
the wood panel with velcro
it's perfect for securely attaching
those phones to the board and still
allowing them to be removed if needed
for example the battery on one of my
phones started swelling just before i
got here so that was a great time to
remove it before it became a fire hazard
on the plane
this was already hard enough to explain
to security
back at home i have a raspberry pi to
coordinate the phones but really you can
use any computer for the server and i'm
going to be demoing here off the left
off this laptop
all these phones need to get charged so
i use some regular usb cables that i had
lying around to keep them plugged in
they're laid out with a bunch of little
tiny wire clips eight eight euros will
get you 100 of these clips in a bag and
then i've laid them out so each clip is
only containing one or two wires
all these wires feed back into a usb hub
so i only need to plug one cable into a
power outlet
i have here a usb hub that i got from a
junkyard 15 years ago
but similar hubs can be found for about
20 euros
all in all a total price of around 75
euros isn't too bad and really for a
cool project like this that you build
yourself the bragging rights are worth
so much more
plus you probably do have some of these
items already and that knocks the cost
down
so that's how you build the hardware
now let's talk about getting these
phones connected
usually phones and computers communicate
to a server
for the internet over wi-fi
but some of these phones don't have
working wifi
these usb cables aren't just for show
and aren't just for power
we can also use them to send data and
commands
all the phones are hooked up to the usb
hub which is then connected to power and
to the raspberry pi server
all these phones run android
so i'm using a program from google
called the android debug bridge to
communicate with them
this program called adb for short is
normally used for developing android
apps if you've tested your website on a
live android phone you might have even
used adb before
but
these tools for developing and debugging
are also great for hacker projects
each phone has a unique serial code that
we can then use with adb to target
commands at it from the command line
you can run the command adb devices to
see a list of connected phones similar
to running ls to see a list of files in
a folder
and then you can send commands to
specific phones by specifying the serial
code with this slag
this even lets you open a full unix
shell on your phone
there are lots of commands like install
new app
simulate a button press and open a
website on the phone
it gives you more power than what an app
can do on its own and even lets you send
commands when your phone's screen is off
to your adb you need to allow usb usb
debugging on each phone
there's a link here with instructions
for how to do that and once you're done
you can control the phones from your
computer
and this process is fairly
straightforward
but there are thousands of different
devices running android out there and
some of these phones are 10 years old
so let's talk about some of the
challenges that rise from being old
cheap and or broken
i think the weirdest is that one of
these phones just don't have a serial id
that unique identifier we just talked
about that's a requirement to even use
adv
turns out a couple models just don't
have one
luckily adb devices does have alternate
flags for targeting a specific device
you can run adb devices with the dash l
or long flag which will return longer
output and give you more detail about
your usb connection again a little bit
like ls-l
the usb and transport id columns here
tell you about the usb port the phone is
plugged into and then you can use those
to target a phone with similar adb flags
but it's also not very ideal since your
phone will stay always stay the same but
you can plug into a different port on
your computer
my long-term solution was to root the
phone
rooting is a process similar to jail
breaking an iphone that gives you full
access to a device letting you run
pseudo commands
with that i was able to use an app to
manually change the serial code into
whatever value i wanted
another challenge i ran into is that
this phone doesn't have a working wi-fi
chip anymore
and while we can send some data over usb
i do still want to be able to display
websites so i want to set up an http
connection
turns out you don't need a wi-fi chip
because you can send http requests using
usb
adb lets you set up port forwarding so
localhost port on your computer can be
exposed to the phone over usb
here with requests that are made to the
phone on localhost on port 3000 will be
redirected to the server's localhost on
port 3000 using this adb reverse command
finally the most visible challenge is a
lot of old phones have cracked screens
that don't turn on
i have bad news they're beyond saving
but they do become nice decoration to
stick on the side
but you know if the phone does still
turn on and it's just that the screen
isn't working you can't actually still
use it you can duplicate your phone's
screen to your computer monitor using a
tool called screen copy
even if your phone's screen is broken
his rendering chip still works fine
this also lets you interact with a touch
screen using a mouse and you can set the
phone however you want to use it like
maybe as a music speaker
it's also a really nice tool for mobile
web development
so if adb setup let's dig deeper into
how the server works
[Applause]
maybe the next content is just dry so i
need to get some collapse of the water
all right so adb provides a great tool
for controlling each phone without
worrying about the phone being on the
wi-fi being connected or your app even
being open
was also fairly slow you need input one
command at a time and these old phones
take a few seconds to respond to adb
so now we introduce scripting and turn
to javascript and node.js
going to use a library called appium adb
internally it uses node to run the same
adb commands we just reviewed in a child
process
we can write javascript to get a list of
devices just like on the command line
and now we're able to represent all the
connected phones
using an array in node.js
let's start using note to turn on the
displays and show something
we can start with looping through the
device's array to turn each phone on
and then we'll have some code to wait
until we send a start command with adb
this is another thing i'm going to try
and demo so let's go back to the desk
here
also this is a this is a script that
turns the phones on so i should have
them off first
i see that this works
there we go there we go
this is running the same code i just
show them the slides
okay so back to the slides
now we start running into issues around
communication speed
talking over usb is pretty nice but then
adb is command line and then usb
transfer and then phone refresh dance
takes a few seconds
so let's use the power of the web
to speed up sending data from the server
we've already seen that we can create a
tcp connection using adb
and we can use that connection for http
requests and for websockets websockets
establish a persistent connection
between the server and client for
real-time apps like games or chats
and websockets work well for pushing
small packets of data from the server to
the clients
so after adb is used to launch an app on
each client each client then establishes
a websocket connection to the server
adb still gets used for controlling
power and as a backup system but now
showing data is much faster and only
limited by the cell phone's processing
speed
and using web sockets the server sends
each phone a url
just like the start command
i've pre-made some simple websites like
one to show text and when to show a
clock but really you can take advantage
of all the cool websites out there and
display them you can show weather stocks
and music visualizers
so i want to show off a little bit of
that back on the table
let's see how this goes
oh no
well the clock is working but i'll show
a video of some of the other content
like this little uh oh back of the
slides
there's a little uh
website here if it shows a 3d city that
you can pan around and there's all these
different cool sites out there that
really work super well for just
displaying on these small phones
all right going back uh no i'm already
on the slides i'm just looking at video
each of these cell phones are to steal
tiny computers with a web browser
and even though these phones are around
10 years old the web browser is still up
to date
on this tablet the newest version of
android you can get is android 4.4 from
and the newest web browser i could get
was firefox nightly from last night
[Applause]
all right so what about showing one
thing across all these phones
like splitting up lines of text or
slices of an image
each phone doesn't need to know that
much it just needs to know what what it
wants to show
the server will figure out what each
phone should display
and when
to do that we need the server to figure
out each phone's width and height and x
and y position
with height is pretty easy we can just
read the screen size and javascript and
then send that back to the server
x and y is harder since the server needs
to figure out where these phones are
relative to each relative to each other
in physical space
and
you could use the computer vision ml
library here to look at all the phones
and start determining rectangles and
their position in space
but there's an easier way
human vision and a ruler
these screens are fixed in place so one
time manual setup is much faster
than using that info we can figure out
how to display an image
the server figures out what size to
stretch an image in order to cover every
cell phone
and then for each phone it copies this
image and then we'll crop it
finally it sends each of those phones
one image slice
all right
let's start out live
i brought this webcam here so i can take
a picture of all of you and upload it to
cell wall where we should see a split
across the screens
let me boot up the camera
all right that's the wrong camera
you don't need more of that
okay
three
two one everyone smile
and i'll switch back to the program and
try and upload this onto all the phones
and have that show on the desk here
all right let's give this a shot
so first server reads that and starts
splitting things up and you see some of
the phones are getting image slices
delivered to them but some of them are
not connected to the server anymore
okay so we got one phone showing a slice
you know this is the one i thought was
going to fail i couldn't get to turn on
this morning but now it's the only one
that's connected
thanks grandma that one's working really
well
okay i'm going to show the video anyways
so let's switch back to the slides
you can still see that it can split up
an image around the whole thing
here you can see that ring starts seeing
spread across all these different phones
with some gaps in between
displaying the data in order follows a
similar process here's a function
display some text
each line is split up into an array and
it's going to get distributed amongst
the phone screens
i have a very rough sorting algorithm
here to approximately sort lower x and y
values first
this helps you display data that matches
where you'd expect it to show up when
you read left and right
and with this sending all these all
these screens we can send a message to
the entire wall
i think we're going to skip the demo for
now let's go straight to the video
but you can say hello in all these
different ways
[Applause]
so we've now covered one half of this
architecture diagram let's go into the
other half
with a software setup sawwall is able to
display lots of different visuals
but you do still need to manually
trigger it in node
and would it be much cooler if you could
respond to what's going on in your
home well we have a node server and one
common way to communicate with a server
remotely is create a rest api
let's start by creating a button to turn
the phones on and off remotely
we'll set up a route and then when this
post request comes in we can run the
corresponding adb commands
then a simple web page can show on and
off buttons and i make a post request
when this button is pressed
and really all we've done is simply add
a new input into the same communication
path
now the server can be told when to send
data to the clients in the wall
and we can same principle to integrate
with other services
something fires an http post request to
our server and then we use that as a
signal to do something on the cell
phones
if that sounds familiar to you i just
described web hooks
this system is already used by lots of
services like stripe and github so you
they can push data to your servers
while folks are so well supported they
can be they can even be used with smart
home devices
smart home software is actually a pretty
similar flow to web servers
something happens like a television
turning on or a user navigating to your
site
and then the server does something in
response like dimming the lights or
sending a push notification
both smart home software and web servers
can call web hooks by just making a
regular post request to another server
there's a few different tools i use
there's a few different tools out there
to coordinate smart home devices
i like to use home assistant an open
source project with many contributors
wide device support and support for
locate working on your local network
without relying on an internet
connection
and that last part is going to be pretty
important when i try to demo this on
conference wi-fi
so let's say that whenever someone plays
a song on spotify or on a speaker in my
house i want to show the song name on
cell wall
in home assistant we can watch for
events when a speaker starts playing
music and then when that happens you can
configure it to call your web hook using
a rest api command
so
let's give that a shot
restart the server and see if the phones
reconnect
and go over to the table please
i think i supposed to get cable in here
for the speaker but we'll just make do
with a laptop speaker
all right
oh no it's not
not going
okay and this is where we come with the
live
live demo debug phase
oh i remember that after i launched the
server i need to reconnect the phones
i really this is working it's just my
speaker isn't working it is listening to
the music
[Applause]
oh okay we can get this on the live
stream
my beauty
[Applause]
well it sounds like that you can display
anything you want here
and once again
we've been able to use the power of the
web to put together something pretty
cool
simply having a web server makes it
possible to integrate your software with
smart homes and with the internet of
things
and hopefully you have a better sense of
how all these pieces fit together
and you can use some or all of them in
your own projects
if you're curious to set up home
assistant in your own home there's
instructions on the website to install
it on a raspberry pi or docker container
and i hope this talk has given you new
ideas on giving your old phones a new
life
if you're interested in learning more
about cell wall or any of my other
projects come check out my blog at
tigeroaks.com
let me know your ideas and projects on
twitter and you can find me at not
underscore woods
i also enjoy talking about pwas anything
front end or android related
i know i had so much fun building this
top project and if you end up building
one for yourself too i'd love to see it
thank you all for coming
[Applause]